Der Rasenfunk. Kurzpass. In Italien stirbt im Umfeld eines Fußballspiels ein Fan. Doch die Debatte darum, die nimmt andere Wendungen, als man es sonst so gewohnt war. Warum, wieso, weshalb, darüber wollen wir jetzt hier sprechen mit Kai. Hallo Kai, schön, dass du mal im Rasenfunk bist.
Hallo liebe Rasenfunker und vielen Dank an euch, dass ich mich hier äußern darf bei euch.
Ja, es ist in beiderseitigem Interesse, denn Kai, du bist ein Experte für italienischen Fußball. Als adarticolo71 kann man dir auch auf Twitter folgen. Und der ein oder andere Hörer und die eine oder andere Hörerin könnte dich auch schon kennen.
Das will ich gar nicht ausschließen. Es gibt seit ungefähr zehn Jahren einen Blog von mir, alcavita.com, da hatte ich mir so ein bisschen meine Ideen zum Fandasein in Italien aufgeschrieben. Das hat Leser gefunden, sehr zu meiner großen Überraschung. Und im Laufe der Zeit hat sich das dann entwickelt. Ich habe ein paar Bücher übersetzt zum Thema Ultras, habe an zwei Dokumentationen fürs Fernsehen teilgenommen, wo wir die Themen ein bisschen im breiteren Publikum auch nahegelegt haben. Ansonsten kennen mich viele Leute aus entsprechenden Lesereisen, Vorträgen, Konferenzen. Alles, was man so zu italienischer Fan-Kultur in deutscher Sprache beitragen kann.
Genau. Und du lebst eben in Italien, das muss man noch mit dazu sagen. Und du bist selbst aktiver Fan. Warst du aktiver Fan? Weiß gar nicht, wie ist da jetzt bei dir aktuell der Stand?
Im Moment bin ich weniger aktiv. Dafür gibt es externe und interne Gründe. Also meine Kurve, ich bin Milan-Fan, hat sich in eine Richtung entwickelt, die mir weniger gefällt, so dass ich den Laden da verlassen habe. Und in San Siro einen ganz normalen Familienbereich betrachte. Oder eben am Fernsehen. Ich bin, denke ich, fast 50 Jahre alt und mache jetzt nicht mehr alle Auswärtsfahrten und alle Heimspiele mit, aber hänge schon durchaus noch am Fußball und an dem, was mein Milan dort so veranstaltet.
Ja, davon kommt man ja nie so los, egal was die Vereine mit uns machen. Da könnte ich mich jetzt auch viel mit dir drüber unterhalten, aber unser Thema ist ein trauriges, nämlich der Tod von Daniele Belardinelli, der rund um das Spiel zwischen Inter und Napoli zu Tode kam. Magst du mal kurz alle Hörerinnen und Hörern, die das vielleicht alles gar nicht mitbekommen haben, denn hier in Deutschland spielt das, ehrlich gesagt, keine große Rolle. Mal kurz aufklären, was ist denn da eigentlich passiert?
Am 26. Dezember wurde Fußball gespielt und die große Spiel an dem Abend sollte sein Inter gegen Napoli, Zweiter gegen den Dritten. Durchaus eine sinnvolle Rivalität zwischen beiden Vereinen und auch beiden Fankurven. Sollte ein heißer Tanz werden. Im Vorfeld kam es zu Auseinandersetzungen. Das heißt, eine kleinere Kolonne von Napoli-Fans ohne Polizeibegleitung bewegte sich auf San Siro zu, eine der Zugangstraßen vom Autobahnzubringer und wurden dort erwartet von ca. 120 Ultras von Inter, die die Kolonne dann auf Zeichen angegriffen haben. Die Auseinandersetzungen dauerten so drei Minuten, Polizei war keine zugegen. Im Laufe dieser Auseinandersetzungen, das Ganze wird natürlich im Moment untersucht und wird dann sicherlich irgendwann zu Gericht gebracht werden, wurde ein Fan der befreundeten, der mit Inter befreundeten Ultras aus Varese, Jena Daniele Belardinelli von einem Auto, mindestens einem Auto, in langsamer Fahrt, so sprechen Zeugenaussagen, überrollt. Die Napolitani haben den dann Inter-Fans sozusagen übergeben, das war dann auch das Ende der Streitigkeiten. Die haben den noch schnell ins Krankenhaus gefahren, wo er leider trotz Notoperation im Laufe der Nacht noch verstorben ist und wurden mehrere Ultras von Inter festgesetzt.
Da habe ich schon mal dazu ganz viele Fragen, bevor wir dann zu dem kommen, was dann danach passiert ist. Also natürlich mit dem Vorbehalt laufender Ermittlungen, ganz schwierige Sachlage. Und für mich als jemanden, der hier von Deutschland aus versucht hat, da Dinge zu recherchieren, nochmal doppelt schwer. Aber wenn wir jetzt uns mal kurz das Setup dieses Konflikts angucken, dann hast du es als Auseinandersetzung beschrieben. Ich habe jetzt gerade das Wort Konflikt in den Mund genommen. Ich frage mich, müsste man nicht eher von einem Überfall sprechen, wenn da 120 Fans den gegnerischen Fans auflauern? Jetzt mal ohne die Frage, warum konnte das dann trotzdem passieren? Aber ist das wirklich nur eine Auseinandersetzung?
Sicherlich ist das Setting als eine Art Überfall zu bewerten, wenn man es von außen betrachtet. Da stehen natürlich 120 Leute auf der Zufahrtsstraße zum San Siro, beziehungsweise verstecken sich in der Nebenstraße, werden dann über die Anwesenheit von Napolitanern aufgeklärt und greifen dann an mit Böllern, Fackeln, die Napolitani steigen aus, stellen sich den Kampf und dann kommt es zu einem Kontakt, dann kommt es zu der Auseinandersetzung. Überfall, ja, sicherlich. Auf der anderen Seite stellen sich mir dann eben noch mehr Fragen. Zum Beispiel, wie kann eine Kolonne aus mindestens zwei Kleinbussen und ein paar Autos ca. 1,5 km vom Stadion anreisen, ohne dass sie von der Polizei begleitet werden? Es ist in Italien ganz grundsätzlich so, dass Auswärtsfans lückenlos überwacht werden. Die zivile Einheit, der DIGOS, der Polizei hier, hat das ganz gut unter Kontrolle. Die haben alle Namen, die haben alle Telefonnummern, die informieren sich. Es ist erfahrungsgemäß sehr, sehr selten, wenn nicht fast ausgeschlossen, dass sich Fans sozusagen unbeobachtet über die Autobahn zum San Siro bewegen, ohne dass irgendjemand von der Polizei was weiß. Nun bin ich kein Polizist. Ich kann nur sozusagen mir Fragen stellen, die mir niemand beantwortet. Fakt ist, sie kommen dort in der Kolonne an. Es ist kein Polizist da. Und auch 1,5 Kilometer vom Stadion können sich 120 Fans von Inter mit Kapuzen und Schals dort treffen, ohne dass irgendjemand davon offensichtlich Kenntnis nimmt. Oder irgendetwas dort tut. Oder dort mal Polizisten hinschickt zur Überwachung. Oder mal schaut, was da los ist. Nichts von dem ist passiert. Da stellen sich mir zumindest zwei Fragen. Erstens, war das vorher abgesprochen zwischen Inter und Napoli? Und zweitens, warum ist da keine Polizei? Ich kann keine Antworten geben, aber das sind zwei Fragen, die sich mir aufdrängen nach dann doch fast drei Jahrzehnten Bewegung innerhalb der italienischen Fanszene.
Ja, die werden sicherlich auch auf irgendeine Art und Weise noch beantwortet werden in den nächsten Wochen. Dann stellt sich mir die eine Frage noch. Jetzt habe ich von diesem Vorfall mitbekommen, weil es eben zu diesem, ja, weil es eine Todesfolge hatte, weil Daniele Belardinelli an den Folgen dieses Überfahrenwerdens gestorben ist. Wie oft gibt es denn solche Auseinandersetzungen im italienischen Fußball, von denen ich dann hier in Deutschland nichts mitbekomme, weil vielleicht nicht die tragischste aller Folgen eintritt?
Mittlerweile praktisch kaum noch. Es war für diese Saison vermutlich auch im weiteren Saisonverlauf ein sehr singuläres Ereignis, was die Serie anbetrifft. Wir haben ja alle die Bilder von den sprichwörtlichen italienischen Verhältnissen im Kopf. Nur bezieht sich das, so ähnlich wie der Catenaccio im gespielten Fußball, auf Bilder der 80er und 90er Jahre, als die Stadien hier alle voll waren, als sich Zehntausende von Leuten auf Auswärtsfahrt begeben haben. Und als es tatsächlich zu massiven Auseinandersetzungen kam, das hat sich seit ungefähr Mitte der 90er Jahre dann tatsächlich immer weiter reduziert durch Aufrüstung der Stadien, Vergrößerung der Polizeikräfte, verschiedene andere Sicherungsmaßnahmen, sodass es zu direkten Kontakten sehr, sehr selten kommt, zumindest in den oberen Profi zu liegen. Das kann immer mal passieren, aber das sind in aller Regel Zufallskontakte, beispielsweise auf einem Autobahnrasthof oder auf einem Bahnhof oder Ähnliches, wo man sich sieht und wo die Ultralogik dann bestimmt, man müsste einander angreifen. In der Praxis, solche Szenarien wie vor Inter Napoli, das sind Geschichten, die sehr, sehr, sehr selten passieren, vor allen Dingen in dieser Stärke.
Aber da höre ich dann so ein bisschen raus, dass das seltener passiert hat, eher damit zu tun, dass ein enormer Aufwand von Seiten der Sicherheitsbehörden gefahren wird, auch mit durchaus zweifelhaften Überwachungsmethoden in manchem Bereich, um die Fans voneinander zu trennen. Und das hat weniger damit zu tun, dass sich die Fanszene der Gewalt abgewandt hätte, zumindest in Teilen.
Nein, eine Abwendung von Gewalt seitens der Fanszene gibt es nicht. Es ist eher richtig, es wird ein Riesenaufwand betrieben, um besonders Auswärtsfans unter Kontrolle zu halten. Wenn denn die Auswärtskurven überhaupt offen sind oder die Stadien offen sind, wird ja immer mal wieder erschlossen, so wie jetzt auch für Inter. Da sind ja jetzt vermutlich erst mal die nächsten Auswärtsfahrten komplett verboten. Es sind 0-2-Spiele ohne Zuschauer. Das heißt, der erste Reflex ist, immer das Stadion oder bestimmte Sektoren zu schließen. Wenn das Spiel ein bisschen heißer werden könnte. Es wird tatsächlich ein riesiger Aufwand betrieben mit Telefonüberwachung, Bewegungsüberwachung, Infiltrationen und so weiter, sodass man es immer besser unter Kontrolle hat, was die Gewaltaktivitäten angeht, aber natürlich auch das gesamte Ultra-Phänomen so ein bisschen nach unten hält. Da gab es immer mal wieder Ausschläge nach unten und nach oben, wie fest diese Geschichte, die Repressionsgeschichte angezogen wird. Aber mittlerweile, darauf wollte ich in meinem Eingangsstatement so ein bisschen hinaus, mittlerweile ist es so, dass sich Auswärtsfans praktisch nicht mehr frei bewegen können, ohne dass sie sozusagen lückenlos überwacht werden. Ein anderer Aspekt ist natürlich, deswegen sagte ich auch, in den 80er, 90er Jahren waren die Stadien immer voll, es ist ein ganz genereller Rückgang der Zuschauerzahlen. Das heißt, italienische Stadien sind ganz selten voll, Auswärtsblöcke sind selten voll und der Rückgang von Zuschauern, insbesondere von Auswärtszuschauern, sorgt natürlich auch dafür, dass weniger passiert. Wenn keiner mehr hingeht, dann passiert aber nichts.
Ja gut, wobei natürlich der harte Kern trotzdem kommt. Der gewinnt dann natürlich eher noch an Bedeutung. Jetzt gab es ja rund um diesen Vorfall, Überfall, wie auch immer wir es nennen wollen, gab es noch vier weitere Verletzte durch Stichverletzung. Das waren, wenn ich richtig recherchiert habe, alles dann Napoli-Fans. Jetzt hört man gerade davon durchaus häufiger etwas, also durch Verletzung, durch Stichverletzung, auch durchaus bei Auswärtsfahrten deutscher Vereine nach Italien. Ist das ein Teil der Fankultur, dass der Einsatz von Stichwaffen nicht verpönt ist? Ist das normal oder ist das eine neue Form der Gewalt, die eben immer mal wieder auftritt?
Es ist weder normal noch ist es eine neue Form der Gewalt, die immer mal wieder auftritt. Es ist, jetzt mache ich mich höchstwahrscheinlich sehr unbeliebt bei vielen Ultras auch in Deutschland, aber es ist leider unabhängig von dem, was kommuniziert wird. Wir nur mit den Fäusten und nur Angriffe, die 30 gegen 30 und alles ausgewogen und sportlich usw. in der Praxis nahmen und nehmen viele Ultra-Gruppen Messer auf Auswärtsfahrt mit und Heimkurven nehmen viele leider auswärts und mit. Das würde niemand zugeben, das ist immer so ein bisschen verpönt. Das heißt, viele reden nicht darüber, andere machen sich daraus nichts und nehmen Messer mit. Es ist leider eine Geschichte, die die italienische Ultra-Bewegung seit ihrer Gründung mit sich zieht. Nicht völlig ohne Debatten, ich will es nicht alles sozusagen in einen Top werfen. Es gab auch immer Fanszenen, die die Anwendung von Stichwaffen grundsätzlich abgelehnt hat und die auch bei sowas niemals erwischt wurden. Und es gab auch in der Vergangenheit tatsächlich Debatten innerhalb der italienischen Ultrawelt Stichwaffen grundsätzlich zu ächten. Das wurde dann leider niemals von allen getragen und war auch niemals besonders langlebig, sodass sie weiterhin diese beiden Schulen so ein bisschen, in Anführungsstrichen Schulen, aufeinandertreffen. Beispielsweise Fanszenen wie Atalanta oder Catania, die Stichwaffen grundsätzlich ablehnen und nicht einsetzen. Und andere Fanszenen wie eben leider auch Inter- oder die Römer-Szenen oder eben auch Napoli, die sowas auch gerne mal dabei haben.
Ja, jetzt hätte ich noch eine sehr große Frage, bevor ich dann gerne mit dir wieder auf den konkreten Fall zurückkommen würde. Jetzt gab es ja im italienischen Fußball schon häufige Todesfälle im Fan-Umfeld. Hatte oft mit Auseinandersetzung auch oder mit Aufeinandertreffen mit der Polizei zu tun, aber ja durchaus auch zum Beispiel Giro Esposito vor dem Pokalfinale. Ein Napoli-Fan, der von einem Hooligan des AS Rom erschossen wurde. Der hatte auf ihn und zwei weitere Anhänger geschossen. Das sind sehr drastische Fälle. Warum spielt Gewalt dennoch in der italienischen Fanszene und damit will ich nicht sagen, dass es nur in Italien so ist, aber wir reden jetzt über Italien. Warum spielt das dennoch eine so große Rolle? Warum haben auch diese krassen Todesfälle nicht dafür gesorgt, dass da ein Umdenken eingesetzt hat? Kannst du mir das erklären?
Ich habe mir selbstverständlich Gedanken dazu gemacht, ob ich es erklären kann, weiß ich nicht. Ich denke, einer der Hauptpunkte, die man beachten sollte, egal, wie man es dann bewertet, ist, der Zwang zur Auseinandersetzung ist Kernbestandteil der Ultralogik. Insbesondere hier in Italien. Das ist schon ein Unterschied zu Deutschland, wo man ab Gründung sozusagen der Bewegung schon durchaus in der Lage war zu erkennen, dass das Ganze eben auch eine Bewegung ist, die bewahrenswerte Inhalte hat, die es zu schützen gilt, die eben bei allen Unterschieden, die man haben kann, haben eben Ultra-Gruppen auch vieles gemeinsam, für das es zu kämpfen gilt oder für das es einzustehen gilt oder was es zu bewahren gilt. Es gibt innerhalb der Ultraszene ja durchaus immer konfliktuale und widersprüchliche Aspekte. Einer ist, dass Ultra eine Bewegung ist, dass Ultra ein gemeinsames Tun und Denken ist, an dem alle Gruppen teilnehmen. Auf der anderen Seite besagt die Ultralogik, dass wenn eine Ultra-Gruppe auf eine andere Verfeindete trifft, dass es dann zur Auseinandersetzung kommen muss und dass man diese Auseinandersetzung suchen muss. In Deutschland gab es schon immer seit Gründung diesen Aspekt, dass Ultra etwas Bewahrenswertes ist. Dass es etwas Schönes ist, dass Ultra-Gruppen bei allen ihren Unterschiedlichkeiten eben auch Teil einer gemeinsamen Bewegung sind, die viele 10.000 Menschen eint. In Italien ist das wohl auch so. Allerdings ist das Bewusstsein dafür schwächer ausgeprägt und es gewinnt häufig bzw. immer die Logik der Gewalt. Das heißt, dieser Punkt der sogenannten Ultramentalität, der fordert, wenn ich gegnerische Ultra-Gruppen sehe, dann muss ich mich mit denen auseinandersetzen körperlich oder ich muss das zumindest versuchen. Das heißt, der Gewaltaspekt lässt sich nicht vom Ultraaspekt trennen. Und als solches wurde die Bewegung in Italien auch tatsächlich immer fortgeführt. Wenn eine Ultra-Gruppe einander sieht, dann wird der Kontakt gesucht und dann wird versucht, eine körperliche Auseinandersetzung mit dem Gegner zu führen, um dann seine Vorherrschaft zu zementieren.
Okay, da allein über den Punkt könnte ich ewig mit dir diskutieren. Aber wir wollen ja jetzt über diesen einen speziellen Fall sprechen. Denn das, was danach kam und so habe ich es dann bei dir im Blog gelesen und wurde so dann darauf auch aufmerksam, das unterscheidet sich durchaus von den Reaktionen, die man bisher hatte bei solchen Vorfällen. Zunächst ging das, ich nenne es mal das Rainer Wendt-artige los. Das heißt das fordern von drakonischen Maßnahmen, von Kollektivstrafen. Aber dann setzte da ein Umdenken ein. Kannst du mal den Hörern und Hörern schildern, was ist jetzt im Nachgang zu diesem Todesfall passiert?
Also Rainer Wendt ist ein ganz guter Hinweis. Also das, was typischerweise immer passiert, egal ob das jetzt ist in Deutschland oder in Italien, da unterscheiden sich die beiden Länder jetzt nicht. Es kommt zu einer Auseinandersetzung und es gibt einen medialen Reflex, der das selbstverständlich alles verurteilt und das brauchen wir nicht. Und die zerstören unseren Fußball und wir brauchen, um das Problem zu lösen, jetzt noch stärkere Strafen und noch mehr Einschränkungen und lebenslanges Stadionverbot und so weiter. Und so wurde das sozusagen seit den 90er Jahren, ich nenne es Repressionsspirale, weil es doch tatsächlich eine selbstverstärkende Spirale ist, von immer neuen Maßnahmen, immer neuen Überwachungen, immer neuen Einschränkungen. Es war fast über ein Jahr, fast ein Jahrzehnt lang in Italien beispielsweise Megafone und Trommeln verboten. Also ganz oder Fahnen mussten angemeldet werden, schriftlich genau wie Choreografien und so weiter. Das war tatsächlich eine Verbots- und Repressionsstrategie unterworfen, die eben auch weit über das hinausgeht, was Gewalt bedeuten könnte. So war es immer, immer mathematisch. Dazu mussten nicht Leute zu Tode kommen, dazu reicht auch eine einentzündete Facke oder irgendwas anderes der Art. Die öffentliche Meinung ist grundsätzlich gegen Ultras eingestellt und die machen ja nur Theater und die machen nur Gewalt und die machen alles kaputt und insofern brauchen wir da höhere Strafen. Da hat man das jetzt 20 Jahre lang so weitergetrieben mit immer höheren Strafen und immer groteskeren Verzerrungen. Stadionverbote für Gruppen, doppelte Stadionverbote für die sogenannten Capos, also die Chefs einer Gruppe oder einer Gruppe. Na, die kriegt einfach die doppelte Zahl. Mach dir jetzt mal ein Beispiel, ein Bus mit 50 Leuten fährt zu einem Auswärtsspiel, obwohl dort die Auswärtskurve geschlossen ist. Also unterstellt man, dass dieser ganze Bus kriminelle Aktivitäten im Hinterkopf hätte, dann fängt man diesen Bus ab, dann kriegen die erst mal alle Stadionverbot. Das Standard sind so drei Jahre, da spricht die Polizei direkt aus. Der Capo in dem Bus bekäme dann sechs, einfach weil der Chef von dem ganzen Laden ist.
Also eben diese Repressionsspirale, wie du sie nennst, das war der Standard-Effekt. Und sag mir noch kurz, wie kam es denn, dass jetzt dann nach über zehn Jahren Fahnen- und Trommeln-Megafone gerade wieder erlaubt wurden? Hat man festgestellt, dass man mit Trommeln dann doch eher seltener anderen auf die Birne kloppt?
Na ja, wenn es so einfach wäre, ich glaube nicht, dass am Anfang jemand daran gedacht hätte, dass man anderen Leuten mit einer Trommel auf die Birne klopft. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es tatsächlich um Gewalt ging, als Megafone Trommeln, Fahnen und alles Mögliche verboten wurden, sondern es ging schlichtweg immer darum, ultra weniger interessant zu machen, ultra weniger attraktiv zu machen und ultra als solches zu beenden. Das heißt, Innenminister Maroni seinerzeit bei der Einführung der ungeliebten Fan-Karte Tesserate Tifoso, die alle brauchten, die auf Auswärtsfahrten gehen wollten, der hat gesagt, wir müssen das Ultra-Phänomen eliminieren, wirklich. Und das gewünschte Mittel dazu war, denen alles das zu nehmen, was typischerweise junge Generationen anzieht. Das ist ja nicht so, dass ein zwölf-, dreizehnjähriger People, der sich so eine Kurve anguckt, von der Gewalt anbezogen wird, die eventuell auch eine Rolle spielt in dem Ganzen, sondern der guckt dahin. Ich kenne meinen eigenen Sohn, ist jahrelang mit mir in den Stadion gegangen, der hing natürlich mit den Augen nicht ums Spielfeld, sondern die haben da gesungen und haben da Rauchtöpfe angezündet und Bürotechnik, aber immer völlig begeistert von dem, was da passiert in den Kurven, was man sehen und was man hören kann. Das ist ja auch das, was Fans typischerweise begeistert in so einem Stadion ist, was die Kurven dort aufführen und was die Kurven dort ein Schönem aufführen. Insofern hat man das alles verboten und in der Tat mit einigem Erfolg ist eine ganze Generation weggebrochen, die einfach in diesen Kurven nichts Schönes, nichts Buntes, nichts Lautes, nichts Freies mehr gesehen hat. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass man erkannt hat, dass Trommeln und Megafone nichts mit Gewalt zu tun hat. Das wusste man sicherlich auch vorher. Man hatte ein generelles Problem, dass in diesen zehn Jahren man sicherlich die Gewalt verringert hat. Man hat aber auch tatsächlich die Zuschauerzahlen Jahr für Jahr nach unten geschraubt, bis es ein wirtschaftliches Problem wurde. Die italienischen Serie A-Vereine und auch Serie B-Vereine leben ja praktisch nur von den Fernsehrechten. Merchandising-Gadgets findet praktisch nicht statt, wenn nicht in Raubkopform die Einnahmen einer Stadionkasse waren teilweise nicht mehr wahrzunehmen. In vielen Stadien und mit Unterschied von Juventus sind auch Derbys praktisch nicht mehr ausverkauft. Das ist natürlich ein Riesenunterschied gewesen, zu noch vor 15 Jahren, als viele Stadionen, wie auch das dann Ciro praktisch mit Dauerkarten ausverkauft waren und man dort nur per Erbschaft reinkam. Das heißt, ich denke, der wirtschaftliche Hebel war hier eher interessanter. Um Leute ins Stadion zu bekommen, musste man Bürokratie abbauen, Verbote abbauen und Leute tatsächlich in Leuten den Wunsch aufleben lassen, doch wieder mal in den Stadion zu besuchen.
Okay, naja, interessant. Wenn es dann um die Kohle geht, da braucht man dann auf einmal die Fans und dann sind dann vielleicht auch Ultras gar nicht mehr so unwichtig. Aber das ist jetzt ein anderer Themenkomplex. Es hat sich nach den ersten Forderungen, und du hast es ja auch schon genannt, also Auswärtsspiele ohne Fans für Inter, auch Heimspiele ohne Fans für Inter, dass die ganze Klaviatur der Reaktion auf solche Ereignisse wurde gespielt. Und dann hat sich Matteo Salvini gemeldet, der Innenminister Italiens, von dem wir auch in anderem Zusammenhang auch hier in Deutschland schon einiges gehört haben, bevor wir das hier mit in die Diskussion reinbringen, erzähle uns doch erstmal, welche neue Note hat er denn der Debatte um diesen Vorfall gegeben?
Das interessante war, ich denke, hier sollte man auch erwähnen, dass Salvini, wie er es auch selber sagt, seit seinem 15. Lebensjahr Kurven frequentiert hätte. Und er hatte sich dann erstmal zu Wort gemeldet mit dem Effekt, wenn man über Kurven redet, dann wäre es doch ganz schön, wenigstens mal in einer gewesen zu sein. Es gab Bilder von ihm, wie er wenige Tage vorher beim Fest der Covas Sud von Milan dabei war und wie er dort mit den Ultras gemeinsam den 119. Geburtstag von Milan gefeiert hat. Die Bilder gingen dann rum, wir haben da Selfies gemacht mit den Capos von Milan usw. Persönlich hätte da jetzt weniger Freude dran gefunden, aber die Bilder waren halt bekannt, auch im öffentlichen Interesse. Jetzt kommt der Daniele zu Tode, der Umgang zu diesem Spiel und die ersten Pressemeldungen sind immer gleich. Ich kenne das Spiel ja schon seit 20 Jahren. Ultras, die machen unseren Fußball kaputt und da gibt es Tote. Und überhaupt und für ein Fußballspiel soll niemand sterben, alles richtig. Wir müssen jetzt der Polizeichef von Mailand in der Nacht noch forderte, Auswärtsfahrten bis Ende der Saison zu verbieten. Und bei den Heimspielen müsste man mal schauen und die Ultras usw. Am nächsten Tag kommt Salvini vor, sagt erst mal wenig. Und in einem wenige Tage später angesetzten Treffen der Sicherheitsbehörden, gemeinsam mit anderen Vertretern von Polizei und Politik, macht er ganz erstaunliche Aussagen plötzlich. Das muss ja voraussetzen, ich denke, es hat sich in Deutschland schon rumgesprochen, dass Salvini ein populist ist und dass Salvini sicherlich keine Möglichkeit auslassen würde, mit Populismus Stimmung zu machen. Das ist seine Politik, damit ist er erfolgreich.
Und auch ein Rechtspopulist, das kann man schon so sagen. Also Rechtspopulismus kennzeichnet sich ja auch durch so eine starke Kontrolle des Staates aus, dass man eben eher den Stark und die Sicherheitsbehörden stärker machen möchte.
Law and Order, es gibt auch genügend Fotos, wie Salvini in Uniform verschiedener Abteilungen posiert und natürlich den Law and Order starken Mann macht. Ja, er nennt mich Rechtspopulist, aber auf jeden Fall erst mal Populist. Das heißt, er verkauft der öffentlichen Meinung das, was die öffentliche Meinung hören will. Und die öffentliche Meinung ist auch in Italien zu 99 Prozent Anti-Ultra eingeschaltet, sodass, wir hatten Rainer Wendt schon erwähnt, aber in Deutschland gibt es ja genügend Beispiele, eine hochgehaltene Facke typischerweise, dass wird nach stärkeren Strafen zu rufen, weil das in der Bevölkerung halt ankommt. Ultras haben keine Lobby, Ultras braucht niemand, der nicht selber Ultras ist. Und insofern kommt sowas immer ganz gut an. Da gab es Gewalt und also brauchen wir härtere Strafen, mehr Polizei, um das alles einzugrennen. Und dann kann der friedliche Bürger wieder beruhigt in Stadion gehen, wenn er denn ginge. Die in Stadion gehen, die fühlen sich immer sicher. Aber es geht ja darum, um die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung, die eben nicht in Stadion geht. Italien ist da nicht anders. Geschichte der Ultras sind hier 50 Jahre. In 50 Jahren gibt es diesen Schnitt, das Ultra nur gut findet, der da teilnimmt. Alle anderen auch im selben Stadion, auch vom selben Verein. Ganz häufig können wir dem ganzen Phänomen nichts anfangen, weil sie es im Medial vermittelt bekommen. Und da sind eben nur die Gewaltepisoden im Fokus. Insofern assoziiert man Ultras nur mit Gewalt, es sei denn, man fährt auch ab und zu mal mit. Insofern wäre das jetzt ein klassischer Elfmeter gewesen. Hätte er nur noch verwandeln müssen, das Salvini. Und passiert dann plötzlich was Erstaunliches, dass Salvini, der Erfinder des modernen Populismus, sich hinstellt und sagt, ja, wir fahren aber zu den Spielen der Profiligen jedes Wochenende, sind da 12 Millionen Leute unterwegs und von denen sind höchstens 6.000 Gewalttäter. Das statistische Standardargument allerjenigen, die sich gegen Populismus und gegen die reine Events dieser Welt stellen.
Ja, das ist quasi das Pendant zu unserem Oktoberfest-Vergleich. Dass wir sagen, guck doch mal an, an einem Tag Oktoberfest passiert mehr als in einer kompletten Bundesliga-Saison. Worüber reden wir hier eigentlich?
Genau. Und dass man dieses ganze Choreografien und Gesänge und Begeisterung und ein Stadion ohne Fackeln und ohne Rauch... Also er nannte auch tatsächlich Pyrotechnik, aber ohne Gesänge, ohne Gewalt, äh, ohne Gewalt. Aber ohne Gesänge, ohne Farben, ohne begeisterte Fans wäre kein Stadion, das ist kein Fußball, das will er nicht sehen. Und deswegen hätte er auch gestern das italienische Supercup-Finale in Saudi-Arabien nicht verfolgt, weil da eben alles nur restriktiv ist und da dürfen keine Frauen rein und das ist kein Stadion und da sind keine begeisterten Fans. Und sowas würde er sich nicht angucken. Er rief ihn nicht zum Boykott auf, aber er würde sich sowas nicht anschauen. Er erwähnt beispielsweise auch die in Deutschland wohlbekannten, in Italien überhaupt nicht bekannten Fan-Beauftragten. In Italien müssen ja jetzt die Vereine auch Fan-Beauftragte haben, weil das eine UEFA-Norm ist. Das hat man ja komplett ignoriert über die Jahre. Jetzt haben die Vereine alle Fan-Beauftragte, die ignoriert werden, sowohl vom Verein als auch von den Ultraszenen. Aber er sagte, wir brauchen so ein Mittel zur Kommunikation mit den Fanszenen, um die gemäßigten Kräfte zu stärken, die Gewalttäter zu isolieren und tatsächlich nur die zu bestrafen, die sich was zu Schulden kommen lassen haben in diesem Tenor. Ich würde das genaue Gegenteil von einer populistischen, wohlbekannten Antwort darauf, von der Person, die in Italien Populismus betreibt wie kein anderer. Das fand ich schon in der Tat sehr, sehr erstaunlich. Und um jetzt sozusagen die Sorge oder die Frage aufzugreifen, will er sich denn da nicht nur an rechtsgerichtete Ultrakurven rankuscheln? Rechtsgerichtete Kurven aus dem Norden wählen, typischerweise ganz häufig sowieso, lega Nord. Das haben sie vorher vor Salvini getan. Das werden sie auch nach Salvini tun. Das ist leider ein Phänomen im Norden. Es ist eine Partei, die gut verwurzelt ist in diesem Ambiente. Auch wenn parteipolitisch tatsächlich nicht viel geht in Ultrakurven. Bei Wahlentscheidungen kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass eine ganze Menge der Nordkurven tatsächlich lega wählen. Das hätte er nicht nötig. Vor allen Dingen sind 99 % der italienischen Bevölkerung trotzdem Anti-Ultra eingestellt. Das heißt, er würde sich heranschleimen an ein paar Tausend Leute. Dafür aber viele Millionen Italiener vor den Kopf stoßen, mit solchen Aussagen, die er trotzdem gemacht hat.
Ja, gut. Aber das ist natürlich schon ein interessanter Punkt. Ich habe auch gelesen, das kann ich jetzt von hier schwierig bewerten. Aber ich habe gelesen, dass Belardinelli, der bei Blood & Honor Varese war, einer der führenden Köpfe, dass das durchaus auch eine Kurve mit rechten Sympathien wäre. Du hast es ja auch schon selbst genannt, im italienischen Fußball ist das generell bei vielen, vielen Fanszenen ein Phänomen. Und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist das auch nur, weil das in diesem Spiel kulminiert. Aber wir reden ja hier über die Partie, in der es auch die rassistischen Äußerungen gegenüber Colibali gab, wo Carlo Angelotti das Spiel mehrfach unterbrechen lassen wollte. Am Ende flog dann Colibali vom Platz. Also auch diese Rassismusdebatte fand ja dann in diesem Spiel statt. Das ist jetzt eine Verquickung von zwei Ereignissen, wo ich mir die Frage stelle, ist es von meiner Seite aus gerechtfertigt, da auch einen Bezug herzustellen, dass ich sage, wir haben einen eher recht populistischen, zumindest einen populistischen Innenminister mit einer Biografie, die erklärt, warum er mehr Verständnis für Ultras hat. Wir haben aber auch beteiligte Fans, die aus einem ähnlich gerichteten Weltbild kommen. Und wir haben dann dieses Spiel, bei dem eben auch noch Rassismus stattfindet im Stadion und nicht sanktioniert wird. Das ist wie so ein Brei aus unguten Faktoren, die da zusammenkommen. Und für mich ist es schwierig, das auseinander zu dividieren. Du bist viel näher dran. Hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Man kann das nicht ausschließen. Allerdings ist die Rassismusdebatte in Italien viel, viel lascher als die Gewaltdebatte. Während gegen Ultragewalt sich die von mir zitierten etwas polemischen 99 Prozent aussprechen, die Ultras als Horden von marodierenden, gewalttätigen Subjekten betrachten, ist es bei der Rassismusdebatte was ganz anderes. Es gibt eine Debatte, die gibt es schon immer. Rassismus in Stadien ist leider ein Problem, das sich über die Jahrzehnte hinzieht. Das ist ja auch nichts Neues, was dagegen Kulliballi passiert wird. Es gibt genügend Beispiele aus den letzten Jahren. Und da machen auch nicht nur Kurven mit. Das heißt, diese Kulliballi-Debatte, da ist Italien deutlich mehr in tatsächlich auch große Blöcke geteilt. Viele auch unverdächtige Personen sagen dann, ja, aber gegen Bonucci machen die doch dieselben Laute. Und wer entscheidet denn, ob der weiße Bonucci, wenn die dieselbe UUU machen gegen Bonucci, dann ist der weiß. Und wenn man es gegen Kulliballi macht, ist es plötzlich Rassismus. Da gibt es alle möglichen Diskussionen und Theorien. Und innerhalb der Kurse, wie auch außerhalb der Kurse, dann tatsächlich auch gewichtige Stimmen von, ich will jetzt gar nicht die Mehrheiten benennen, aber die da sagen, gut, da wird halt der Gegner geschmäht. Und nur weil der jetzt schwarz ist, wird da plötzlich so ein Riesentammtamm drum gemacht. Also das ist eine, ich sage nicht die Mehrheitsmeinung, aber schon durchaus eine mehrheitsfähige Meinung. Da sind viel, viel mehr Leute unentschieden bzw. noch abzuholen als bei der Gewaltfrage. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so einfach zu erklären ist. Ich habe ja auch gar keine einfachen Antworten darauf. Aber ich beziehe mich nochmal auf das Ding mit dem Fanbeauftragten. Jetzt kann ja ein Populist, der so ähnlich wie Trump, ja auf alles immer eine einfache Lösung hat oder der zumindest weiß, auf welcher Klaviatur für die öffentliche Meinung er spielen muss. Sonst wäre er nicht da, wo er jetzt ist. Immerhin Vorstand einer Partei mit nur 16 Prozent beim letzten Wahlergebnis. Er sich geriert, als wäre er der Präsident von allem. Er setzt sich trotzdem hin und hat sich auseinandergesetzt mit der Figur des Fanvertreters. Das heißt, er hat davon gehört. Und dann hat er die Mehrheit der Italiener komplett hinter sich gelassen, die diese Figur überhaupt nicht kennen. Oder die Abkürzung. Slor wird er hier genannt in Italien. Supporters, License, Officer, weil man einfach die UEFA-Bezeichnung übernommen hat, übernehmen musste, weil die UEFA die italienischen Vereine gezwungen hat, diese Figur hinzusetzen. Er setzt sich tatsächlich hin und sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt diese Leute da sitzen, und die haben auch tatsächlich eine wichtige Aufgabe. Da sind, glaube ich, in Deutschland die Mehrheit, selbst der Ultra, ist davon überzeugt, dass der Fan-Beauftragte tatsächlich eine wichtige Aufgabe hat. Das muss man ja erst mal wissen. Und das ist auch keine Aussage, mit der man einfach Punkte sammelt bei irgendwelchen Wählern, die von diesem Begriff noch nie was gehört haben. Das heißt, da hat er oder seine Mitarbeiter oder wer auch immer ihm das sozusagen eingeflüstert hat, eine Arbeit gemacht, sich damit auseinandergesetzt, versucht, andere Lösungsansätze zu finden, die er dann dort tatsächlich vor den Sicherheitsbehörden vorgetragen hat. Ich finde, ganz persönlich würde ich gern über Salvini vom Leder ziehen. Nur in diesem Bezug ist es, glaube ich, nicht so einfach.
Das ist ja auch das Besondere dieser Debatte. Deswegen hast du ja auch deinen Blog-Eintrag mit ein Toter kein Populismus überschrieben, weil das eben nicht der klassische Reflex war, der jetzt eben dann von Salvini kam. Ich glaube, wir haben auch ganz gut hergeleitet, woher das jetzt kommt und was das Besondere daran ist. Jetzt würde mich aber dann noch interessieren, was hat denn das mit dieser Debatte gemacht? Glaubst du, es wird in Zukunft jetzt anders über Ultras in Italien gesprochen? Was könnten die Folgen dieses einen Ereignisses sein?
Ich behalte mich mal an die Folgen, die ich sehe. Das heißt, das mediale Karussell wurde nach den Aussagen von Salvini richtig runtergebremst. Man hört praktisch, das Thema ist von den Titelseiten verschwunden. Es gab ein paar Fernsehbeiträge. Vielleicht waren die jetzt auch nicht so ausgewogen, wie ich mir das wünschen würde, aber durchaus besser als das, was man in der Vergangenheit so sehen musste. Das heißt, das Thema wurde runtergekocht. Und ich las tatsächlich auch so Meinung wie, warten wir doch erst mal die Untersuchungsergebnisse ab. Man weiß nicht so genau, was da tatsächlich passiert ist. Vielleicht war es ein Verkehrsunfall. Vielleicht war es ein tatsächlicher Totschlag, dass der Napolifan dort willentlich über den Körper gefahren ist. Das muss man erst mal sehen. Es gab im Fatto Quotidiano einer Tageszeitung, relativ bedeutenden nationalen Tageszeitung hier, tatsächlich einen Artikel, der die Polizeiarbeit an diesem Abend aufgedröselt hat. Der mit internen Dokumenten recherchiert hat. Ausgehend von der Frage, warum war da keine Polizei? Die haben recherchiert, wo waren die, nach welchen Anweisungen, wer hat was gesehen und gesagt und hat entschieden, dort nicht hinzufahren. Und letztlich zu dem Schluss kam, das erste Mal, dass ich glaube ich in 30 Jahren etwas Ähnliches auch nur lese in einem Leitmedium, dass die Mailander Polizei komplett versagt hat, in voller Linie. Und dass es deshalb dazu kam, zu dem, was es gekommen ist. Und dass deshalb jemand liegen geblieben ist am Ende. Diese Schuldzuweisung an die Polizei oder zumindest die Fragestellung, was ist da schiefgelaufen, da wird jemand dafür bezahlt, solche Geschehnisse zu verhindern, hat sie nicht verhindert, da hat jemand seinen Job nicht gemacht und Konsequenzen zu fordern. Das ist das allererste Mal, dass ich sowas lese. In etwas, was nicht nur ein Blog ist oder ein Instagram-Post.
Also könnte man sagen, dass dieses schreckliche, traurige Ereignis zum ersten Mal dazu geführt hat, dass sich die Diskussion zu einem konstruktiveren Ansatz hin verändert?
Im Moment sieht es so aus. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie das tragfähig ist. Salvini liegt sicherlich nicht an den Ultras. Salvini ist kein Ultra, der hier irgendwelche Ultras schützen will. Salvini liegt vermutlich auch nicht mal etwas an den Italienern. Salvini liegt eine Menge an Salvini und an seiner Partei und alles das, was er tut, sorgt für Begeisterung bei Salvini und seiner Partei und eben leider auch bei ganz vielen Leuten. Insofern muss man sehen, wie sich das in der Zukunft entwickelt. Das hängt sicherlich auch von der öffentlichen Meinung ab. Im Moment sind Ansätze zu sehen, die ich hier tatsächlich in Jahrzehnten nicht gesehen habe. Auch an Reflektionen, auch an Fragestellungen. Auch tatsächlich die ganz einfache Frage, hat denn die Polizei alles richtig gemacht? Eine Geschichte, die niemals auch nur jemand hinterfragt hat. Auch bei anderen Toten. Die Schuldfrage war immer klar, wenn die sich da nicht geprügelt hätten, dann wäre auch niemand gestorben. Was natürlich teilweise richtig ist. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man sie dort machen lässt, dann geht mal Risiko ein, dass eben was passiert. Und die Polizei ist dafür da, dafür zu sorgen, dass sowas nicht passiert. Das heißt, es sind Ansätze zu sehen, die ich in Italien so noch nie betrachtet habe. Ich, aufgrund meiner langen Erfahrung, hab immer so ein bisschen natürlich noch das Problem, da jetzt dran zu glauben, dass ein tatsächliches Umdenken stattgefunden hat. Dass wir jetzt alle rational werden. Vor allen Dingen gerade, wenn es mit Salvini verknüpft ist. Der kann ja auch morgen seine Meinung ändern. Wir kennen das von Trump. Aber im Moment sehe ich eine Diskussion oder eine Besonnenheit, die ich vorher so nie gesehen habe. Ich bin hoffnungsvoller, als ich das vorher war. Vorher hatte ich null Hoffnung. Jetzt denke ich, einiges geht eventuell vielleicht sogar tatsächlich in die richtige Richtung. Das heißt, wir können weiterhin Trommeln und Megafone mit reinnehmen. Salvini sagt, von 12 Millionen Fans sind eventuell 6000 gewalttätig. Und um die müssen wir uns kümmern. Und ansonsten Tifo in Support in einem Stadion muss es geben.
Und das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich mit dir darüber sprechen wollte. Weil man hier in den deutschen Medien, zumindest ich habe fast gar nichts dazu gefunden. Die Meldungen, was da passiert ist rund um das Spiel. Ja, aber eben nicht das, was jetzt danach kam. Und dann gucken wir doch einfach, dass wir in Kontakt bleiben und du mich auf dem Laufen enthältst. Wie hat sich die Diskussion weiterentwickelt? Denn ich finde das wirklich interessant. Wir reden hier über das Land der Fußballfans, in dem auch schon ganz, ganz viel an Repressalien umgesetzt wurde, was vielleicht auch so mancher deutscher Politiker sich hier in Deutschland wünschen würde. Wer weiß, wo sich das alles hier hinentwickelt. Und deswegen finde ich es besonders wichtig, dann auch zu gucken, was passiert denn da an anderen Orten. Und vor allem, wenn es auch mal nicht die üblichen Reflexe sind. Sonst wäre dieser Kurzpass viel kürzer geworden, wenn es so gelaufen wäre wie sonst immer.
Ich möchte nur das Ganze dann eben genau mit diesem Gedanken schließen. In Italien wurden Repressionsstrategien, die Teilen der deutschen Politik und Teilen der deutschen Polizei sicherlich feuchte Träume bereiten, durchgesetzt und viele, viele Jahre vorher durchgesetzt und tatsächlich auch weniger rechtsstaatlich durchgesetzt, als man das in Deutschland jemals könnte. Das heißt, vieles von dem, was Law and Order-Politiker und Law and Order-Polizisten in Deutschland fordern, gern möchten, gern durchsetzen möchten, als Problemlösung verkaufen, wurde hier in Italien bereits seit 10 Jahren experimentiert. Im Moment findet selbst beim größten Populisten ein Umdenken statt, weil die Strategie, die gefahren wurde in den letzten 10 Jahren, zu einem desaströsen Ergebnis geführt hat. Denn Tote gibt es weiterhin. Die Stadien hat man mittlerweile zur Hälfte entleert. Und die wirtschaftlichen Fundamente des italienischen Fußballs dadurch angegraben. Das hat zu einem Umdenken geführt. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir uns in Deutschland tatsächlich vor den Kerren spannen sollten solcher Ideen. Denn in Deutschland sind die Ideen voll. In Deutschland gibt es eine riesige Übergeisterung. In Deutschland mag es nicht jedem gefallen, dass in Ultrakurven auch meine Fackel hochgehalten wird. Und ja, es ist verboten. Genauso wie zu schnell fahren auf der Autobahn. Und trotzdem glaube ich, dass wir mit dem deutschen Fußball ein ganz hervorragendes und schützenswertes Gut haben. Und wir sollten vielleicht eventuell zwei, drei Gedanken daran verschwenden, zu gucken, was hier in Italien versucht wurde und mit welchen Ergebnissen das geändert hat. Sodass selbst Leute wie Salvini eventuell auf die Idee kommen zu sagen, es war falsch, wir müssen was ändern. Und wenn wir das hier sehen, dann glaube ich, könnten wir in Deutschland vielleicht auch ruhiger schlafen und sagen, vielleicht haben wir jetzt auch nicht den Druck, unbedingt italienische Verhältnisse herbeizuführen.
Das perfekte Schlusswort war das. Vielen Dank dir, Kai Et Artikolo, 71 auf Twitter. Danke dir, dass du mal im Rasenfunk warst. Ich hoffe, wir können dich hier noch häufiger mal begrüßen. Hat mir großen Spaß gemacht.
Mir auch. Ich danke euch und jedem, der bis jetzt durchgehalten hat. Und wenn es keine größeren Protestmeldungen gibt, dann machen wir das in Zukunft mal wieder.
Sehr gut. Du wirst hoffentlich Feedback bekommen auf Twitter. Und ich leite dir alles andere weiter. Danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass 112. Ich hoffe, ihr hört ihn schnell weg. Denn am Sonntag, in der Nacht von Sonntag auf Montag, kommt ja schon die nächste Schlusskonferenz. Es geht immer weiter. Macht's gut. Bis dahin eine gute Zeit.